[Musique]
vous l'avez peut-être vu circuler cette
vidéo était mise en ligne sur youtube le
7 mars dernier elle a été vue à des
centaines de milliers de reprises et
partager des dizaines de milliers de
reprises sur facebook
en fait c'est un texte narré en france
est issu d'un article publié en anglais
sur un blog conspirationnistes mon
collègue des fiat s'est penché là-dessus
début 2019 j'avais prédit qu'il y ait un
lien entre la singer un faux virus dans
cette vidéo est dans ce texte on affirmé
qu'il y aurait un lien entre la
technologie 5g et la pandémie de kobe de
le problème en fait le gros problème
c'est qu'on ne dit pas en quoi consiste
exactement saunier présumés ensuite nous
avons la société huawei qui propose
d'aider à combattre le soi-disant virus
avec ces mêmes stations de base 5 g
j'espère que les gens vont se réveiller
face à cette faune qui est deux petites
mentions à peine de la technologie 5
gênant tout le reste de ce qui est dit
de ce qui est écrit mais ça renvoie à un
article publié en 2007 j'ai bien dit
2017 soit bien avant la pandémie
actuelle de kobe 19 la vidéo affirme que
la vie de one était un des premiers lieu
de l'implantation du réseau 5g en chine
coïncidence si aussi à one qu'a débuté
la pandémie actuelle de coved 19
en fait le premier pays à déployer
véritablement un réseau 5g ce n'est pas
la chine mais plutôt la corée du sud
donc comme je vous le disais la vidéo ne
parle pas tant que ça de la 5g la
technologie 5 g ou encore du coroner
virus mais tente plutôt de vous
convaincre de l'existence d'un vaste
programme de dépopulation alimenté par
des fausses pandémies créé par des
vaccins
quelle pandémie au juste celles qui
seraient liées au vih à l'ebola ou
encore à la polio tout des pandémies qui
auraient été créées en laboratoire des
vaccins endommageant l'adn ils seront
donc introduit le concept de cette vidéo
est fort simple c'est celui de vous
bombardez d'information pour créer dans
votre esprit la peur et la confusion
méfiez-vous alors pour ne pas devenir
une autre victime de ce que mon collègue
des fillettes s'appelle le bombardement
d'information d'ailleurs le texte de mon
collègue des fillettes est à lire sur
ses liens présumés
il faut entre la technologie 5g et la
pandémie de kobe de 19
n'oubliez pas de nous écrire c'est très
important encore et toujours aux
courriels des décrypteurs aller
consulter notre groupe facebook et notre
page web également salut